[Music]
hey before we get into this piece
videoe uh we wanted to ask Nick a
question before before we introduce Our
Guest Jason today uh we want to ask Nick
um if there's two people right and then
one's molesting the other the other one
doesn't want that but then this one is
also molesting this person at the same
time this person also doesn't want it
what is that wait say that say that one
more time they're msing each other but
they both don't want it is this a
patreon video you say that one more time
can you say that just one more time it
within the now you're get no no no no no
is that a pat what are we talking about
can you just say that one more time
everybody welcome back to another
awesome video of off the Record today we
have a fan favorite
Jason chenny chenny
chenny hey you know what's so cool about
this chinny chin chin yeah I messaged
him cuz I knew he was coming today so I
said hey dude what is your shirt size
cuz I'm going to send you a shirt I'm
I'm going to have a shirt ready for you
and this fool screenshotted that shirt
because it took like a it was going to
take a month a month but you got it so
fast I got it because I think it's
because they Jesus knows I'm a nice
person and they give it to me faster but
it's because I really like it why is
your shirt different than mine
screenshotted what do you mean he
screenshotted he he screenshotted that
he bought this and then
he
okay that's so nice of you dude no
because I love it I was going to get it
but because I really like you really
bought that on your own yeah because I
wanted it shirt what did you like about
it because it says fear everyone I don't
want a tattoo that's too crazy why not I
know everybody got the thing you going
to get it with
us no you don't want to be a part of the
careful boy crew dude you want to join
the [__] gowok J dude this is your
say you know what this is what happens
you ready wow we always have a thing to
do when a milestone hits when you get
your Netflix special oh yeah you should
wear shorts on stage
yeah he said it he said okay oh shook my
head no that was a forceful that was a
hand rape no that's not hand rape that
is you forced it in hand
rap we're not trying to be on YouTube
huh no bleep bleep patreon Stars yeah D
make the note dude where did you get
that shirt though Gio gave it to
me wait Gio gave it to you GI made gave
it to him it's Gio's new brand sounds
gay I'm in let's go let's go anything
gay then I say yay wow that's a another
shirt that's another shirt huh okay
works too hey gay okay that's
that's good that's good so how you been
man I've been um buying our shirts yeah
bu shirt yeah I
got who would have thought they'd ask
you that yeah you could click on the
link in the description box below you
could get the shirt yourself that sounds
gay I'm in one no these not care this
isn't this like the um the most popular
one fear everyone it looks like it it
looks like the most popular one is that
one in the beige too the baby yeah I
mean we were doing a really really huge
campaign of marketing for it when we
tattooed our legs for Life yep yeah I
think that was a big deal wait what why
does yours look off color your color
maybe it's because uh why are you
talking about my skin color no no no oh
my eyes are up here honey my off color
who says that it a little says that
would you get extra extra small or did
you get extra big dude no I got extra
extra are you blessing a little bit what
size shirt is that is it large but then
I was like in a large
it up I know large look baggy on me what
size your underwear I came what size
your underwear wow yeah you wear large
underwear
medium is smaller oh yeah so so big body
but
smaller so you have a bunch of extra
room in the front exactly yeah me too
but it's extra small for
me but anyway so what's up with you you
didn't answer the question yeah man well
you asked me two questions just now what
was it Joe said a thing Joe always says
a thing but whatever's last yeah you
know I don't know whatever the last
thing or whoever's louder so what's up
with you like that okay I'm that's a
good voice loud voice that scared me a
little bit you scared your guest I have
a I have a deep voice like that Nick
uses his karate voice sometimes but just
answer the question what's up with you
man how's everything yeah good I saw you
posted you got like a 20 City tour right
20 C maybe tell everyone maybe you could
tell everybody about they come come out
and see you thank you so much for
plugging my tour you're welcome Hey JK
fans come through huh yeah and
they're okay I don't know I was going to
say and they're really nice but I I said
that already but um so say something
different okay they're um passionate
passionate and they're uh some of them
are black that's cool some of them are
Asian yeah that's cool he that's exactly
our fan base that's exactly it some of
them are black and some of them are
Asian though some of them are also not
black or Asian that's it that I was
going to say that okay cool damn more
than think and I and I like that but um
yeah so that's where can they go what
link can they go to see all the oh yeah
please um maybe the link in the
description Maybe not maybe Jason ch.com
maybe link and bio no no no no no go to
his Instagram I got to post it on
YouTube but tell them tell them
Instagram Jason chenny Doom Jason chenny
Jason jenny.com is my handle no just
Jason Jenny and all the things you know
do the tour thing and uh do the yeah we
already got a lot of people that bought
tickets
whatk have you have you uh twir T All
Over America I feel like most of the
what area is your most favorite where
you go like oh I can't wait to go to
this you know what if like a underrated
uh City I feel like DC is pretty
underrated really yeah we don't hear
about DC very much so you always heard
about him from Dave Chappelle so you
have all these politicians in your
audience no they're like
um no okay you were going to say black
people really what's DC there's a lot of
black people there what's so underrated
about it I don't know like their food is
nice I didn't think I didn't know DC had
food that's what I thought well I mean
like a regional dish you know like like
Louisiana like fried chicken chick or
whatever Texas barbecue I never heard of
Washington DC [__] KFC Subways yeah
super underrated but what is it though
what is the we went to like this um this
vegan Mediterranean restaurant what you
already lost me at that no but that's
what I'm saying is that usually it's not
great but then this place they had like
Vietnamese beautiful Vietnamese women as
waitresses they come and they like
massage you a little bit so it's most
about the waitresses no but the food is
also good so it's vegan Mediterranean
with Vietnamese yes but also they have
like Korean people to come and serve you
and cut up like a little meatball thing
it's a different thing but the food is
Mediterranean about the bus boys what
races are they they're gay okay I'm in
they're the gay race yeah yeah gay gay
bus boys bu boys is be gay Korean
meatball Cutters Korean meatball Cutters
the play Vietnamese massagers um massage
for you I got to look it up I got but it
it's a really I want to look it up right
now who's making the falafal who's
making the vegan falafal the the gay
Middle Easterns okay gay Middle Eastern
yeah so it's pretty diverse they flip it
they smash it and then they they toss it
you know what I was just a little upset
that um Joe didn't like the
Mediterranean so I had to
like sebast it up yeah yeah yeah to put
a little put some you had a sebast up
yeah wait what you talk about I love I
love
Mediterranean you mean the Vietnamese
thing with the massage you heard of saaz
yeah saaz what was that word the the
spazazz that's Paz Paz pazaz yeah but in
Mediterranean they say
saaz in
mediterrania no I like Mediterranean I
do for me Mediterranean is like Thai
food where there's a [__] ton but only
1% is good
that's true you know what I mean like
how many Kebab places have you been to
it's just
like and then there's a couple that are
like damn like Saharas is [__] good
banging but then after that you're going
to eat about 49 other ones before you
have another niom one I will say veggie
Falafel is one of like the worst foods
in the world really I've had nothing but
bad veggie Falafel yeah it's just
disgusting wait what's a veggie fla is
it just like fried veggie potato yeah
but and then they mix and then chickp it
they mix like cardboard in it or
something why do they do that to make it
taste awful no but it's authentic fful
awful I think that's their own way of
trying to keep people good it's full of
awful that's what we want we want that I
think it's the authenticity cuz you know
remember back then when like there is
famine and and War yeah and then so they
would give give them I think we have
that now still no yeah yeah but less
before more it's more of a throwback
there was it's a throwback good old days
the're good old days where there's a lot
of famine do your does your Chinese
families talk about famine yeah well
growing up they always like you know
don't flush we were just I was talking
about this with my friend like courtesy
flush I didn't know that I I learned
about courtesy flush 4 years ago that's
a privileged thing though I I I learned
it four years ago I understand to do the
you don't have to yell at me about it
just saying okay I was just a little
passion courtesy flush he's right now
you're about to teach right now okay
it's like if you take a dooo yeah which
is dooo is like a [__] in the toilet yep
I know what that is if if you go into
somebody's house you flush it right when
your [__] comes out the [__] can I
say it
sorry sorry I got excited like I got
excited that you got excited I'm sorry
but I was really excited I just love
talking about this kind of stuff I'll
say for him you poop you flush it right
away so sometimes if you have four poops
come out you'll flush four times yeah so
that it doesn't smell so it doesn't
smell at all you're constantly just
flushing I thought that the smell came
from your butthole being exposed to the
air not because of your poop cuz how to
smell go through the water and then go
into the atmosphere the poop coming out
of your butthole that Gap like if you
took that poop and you put it on a
string and you just try to hypnotize
someone it's going to smell like [__] in
but also sometimes you take a [__] and
the [__] float to the top and then a
little bit of gas got to flush that yeah
or you got like a huge log and the water
happens to be a little shallow in that
bowl why is the water shallow sometimes
the
shallow I've done this before whatever
that song is I've done this before where
I flush too much and then you you got to
wait cuz you hit the thing and then
there's no water for the pressure so you
just wait and then has to build and it
Go and it goes all the way to the top
and then you can flush that's how
toilets
work yeah but I just learned about the
cesy yeah yeah yeah so did he but but
the thing did you know not not know
about the courtesy flash I don't do that
yeah I don't do that either he's not
offended spray air freshener because
that's when like but my parents would be
like don't waste water that's what I'm
saying that's more common flush it twice
that's what I'm saying it's a privileged
thing it's a privileg thing but in
California do you remember if it's brown
flush it down if it's yellow make it
mellow let it mellow look I'll say this
if you're sharing a toilet with a bunch
of people I think it's good to Courtesy
flush but if you're [__] in your own
house and no one's home you just let it
ride baby yeah collect four shits before
you flush it yeah you let it ride yeah
oh man 100 wait four is a lot collect
your for shits Ryan yeah if the only
person who's smelling your own Kaka
that's poop as well that's dirty guys
and if you're married if you're married
sometimes in that toilet I'll see a
[__] red tampon dookie wow [__]
pee [__] you're basically talking
about Gio Boogie no boogies like kid
boogies on there cuz only kid yeah kid
boogies on the kleenex all in the same
toilet dude it's pretty crazy and then a
[__] Ninja Turtle Band-Aid yeah
that's always all in the same toilet
it's Ninja Turtle Band-Aid that's also
privileged by the way well let me ask
you with the hair cuz you know you guys
have the wife and girlfriend thing hair
doesn't go in the toilet no no I know
okay sometimes it ends up in there
though sometimes it ends up
there just my wife's hair gets [__]
everywhere though yeah but does it clog
your your drains yeah absolutely the
shower drain but can I say something
dude you got to get a snake you have a
snake it's an animal called a reptile no
no no don't don't do this to me just get
the dro there's a Dro F the dro Dro
speaking Chinese there's a Dr not
specifically for hair and it's great it
it vaporizes it like acid dude I like
doing the snake though there's a joy
there's a satisfaction it's disgusting
but there's a satis can I tell you
something Jason yeah since I got a snake
yeah I probably used it three or four
times is it king cobra or is it like
python hey that's a good fallback career
there's not going to be enough plumbers
in the world that's what I'm saying you
could make a [__] ton of money people
will call a plumber to be like can you
snake my drain and it's like a little
bit of hair and then it runs perfectly
but as soon as you do it you're like I
can be a plumber yeah but sometimes the
snake is two things
you know what I mean like to and then
now your snake is like I only like this
way yeah yeah but then there's a way to
like you know get down the other I'm in
the house sck and I use a [__] wire
hanger and I just uncoil the
wire that works yeah you're handyman
you're how long is your girl's hair how
long does it go on her back does it is
it long dude my wife her hair goes all
the way to her [__] ass right so it's
[__] very long C everywhere so
sometimes when I'm like changing I'll
find piece of hair in my underwear bro
you pull it out of I'm trying to get all
one one little strand it's disgusting
but it's kind of tight huh between a
butt cheeks dude it ends it ends up on
my butt cheek and I'm pulling it all the
way out and it'll take me it's like a
little game I play it's a little mini
game I play and does it not break
sometimes it doesn't most of the time I
I get it without breaking I don't want
to brag I don't want to brag I'm trying
to be humble she has really good hair so
you're just flossing basically little
bit he's a butt floss you use your
wife's hair to floss your ass I don't
put it there it just ends up there he
flosses his ass with you guys ever like
take the floss at the end it it you at
the end of the floss you pull it and
then there a little bit left yeah and
you're like [__] man yeah I don't like I
put a gun in my mouth right after I go
[__] you what's the point and then I
[__] out and then I get really
sad so like how how's your
baby
baby I like how this fool has a baby on
board the caution thing on his on his
car yeah you put you put one on huh or
was wife's idea no no I wanted it but
she bought it but I wanted it does it
make a difference in like driving
experience it does it does but when um
when the baby's not on board and I'm
texting you got harsher judgment no no
they they go okay he's got a baby but I
don't have a baby yeah you got to send
his text what you got to send those
texts I got to those when I'm alone but
when there's a baby I'm I'm I'm 10 and
to that's good that's good
is it a clear difference when somebody
has a baby on board sign that like other
D I think people are a little more I
would like if I see ay oh [__] they'll
let you in when you're trying to merge
and stuff you drive slower I do drive
slower I'm like oh [__] just in case
especially when I have my my dogs in the
car I drive so slow yeah I drive faster
when there's other people's children in
my car cuz I want to get them away
safely yeah interesting oh okay that's
nice too yep but I'm afraid that if it's
like too fast sometimes Too Furious yeah
Too Fast Too Furious and they they get
anxiety
yeah you no so funny yeah babies get
anxiety all the time for sure it's
called baby anxi you know it's like bab
do bab have anxiety like sometimes I
like if we Bon Her Head yeah like
accidentally or whatever but they always
look at you to be like oh is this bad
but we always go yay it's fine but then
I wonder if that's gaslighting them it
you we're gaslighting them is you know
what I mean like you're fine and then
she's [__] bleeding how often do you
Bonker
not not not cuz you accidentally end
whatever what's the recommended amount
only when you walking through doorways
huh that's a that's probably a hot spot
do you believe inid oh um boys oh girls
maybe not do you have a do you have a
son or you son and a daughter or just a
no just daughter so do you think there's
a difference where you see like oh my
baby girl I could never [__] you up and
then if it's a boy it's like I can't
wait to spank you no I don't want to
wait to spank you but I want to maybe
hit you a couple times couple times I
don't know though but cuz I've never
been in a situ I don't think I I don't
know how old is she she's 8 months oh
okay what do you mean you don't know
like you never got hit no I got hit all
the time but I just don't know if I
could do that to my tell do you think
you ever got gas lit as a kid
of course yeah if you're an Asian kid I
think you got Gass it for sure yeah for
sure well you know my my my mom still
does this she will do the thing where
she goes I told you I [__] told you a
month ago right but in my head I'm like
I don't think he told me but she's so
confident that I'm like I think she told
me I guess you did yeah I guess easier
to just say I think you told me but
she's confident every time so maybe I'm
like I'm you know like maybe I forgot I
don't think they're gaslighting I think
they have a very strong
imagination it just they believe it too
they believe it I think they believe it
too and then they then they manifested
their history yeah so they're just like
I don't know if it happened or not but I
think it happened so it happened they're
probably gaslighting their imagination
then that's what it that's what it is
they Gaslight themselves imagination and
then they just say the truth that they
Asian parent delusion is like really on
on the on the line of uh psychotic like
like how your dad said he never hit you
oh yeah but you know what though my
cousins told me they they they
confronted their father my uncle said
the same thing to him oh we were like
great parents you never we never [__]
you up or anything like that you you too
bro I this is like whoa wait you never
[__] up your kids like I've seen you
[__] them up and goes h i mean once in a
while I had to spank them but like Dam
none of the you guys are exaggerating
you guys are weak like that's the kind
of [__] they say and I'm like no I Saw
You full fist punch you know I'm
like you are a [__] lying sack of
[__] but they're not lying they're I
think they're so delusional like it's
probably hard to just and like even
remember that you did [__] like that
that happened to but is that is that
what happened yeah it's the same thing I
I called my dad out like three year
three 3 weeks ago or something and then
um he was like no I don't know why
Jason's like that like in the text chain
like yeah I don't know why Jason's like
that he he had the best
childhood like ever and my wife like
seen my yeah I don't want to but yeah
but uh but yeah no it's okay go to a
dark place no no I just don't want to
you should go to the dark place yeah
tell us the details you just you
literally said nothing you said I have a
story it started and then it ended
that's what you
said dude you're a good interrogator
man in my stomach I'm like I want to
tell you everything tell me
everything no I just uh but
basically uh it's just we're out of time
we're going to have to tune in around
thank you guys for joining
[Music]
us